Wir machen heute was kleines, und zwar bauen wir heute endlich mal so ein kleines Bash-Skript
zusammen für die Hintergründe. Und dann uploaden wir das Ganze auf GitHub und erwähnen natürlich
auch den Rackman, dass die Bilder alle von ihm sind. Machen wir mal kurz die VM an. Also
wir uploaden das alles auf ShitHub. Ich bin plötzlich mal ganz sicher, Google Drive, wo ich
es habe. Drive, was ist das hier? Ja, das sieht gut aus. White Paper Happy Time. Mal umsortieren,
Firefox aufmachen. Mal updaten, weil es ist Archlinux, es hat immer Updates. Weißt du?
Ach, ich dachte es hat immer Updates. So, was wir jetzt machen ist folgendes. Wir laden uns
die ganzen Backgrounds runter. Wie geht denn das hier? Wie kann man alles runterladen? So,
wir laden uns die ganzen Backgrounds runter und dann basteln wir einen Skript,
was irgendwie so anhand der Tageszeit die Backgrounds ändert und das war's. Irgendwie
gescheit ist nicht dieses komische Ding, was letztens da Chat-GPT ausgespuckt hat.
Ja, ich kann ja schon mal das Bizzar Stream richtig angelaufen ist. Ich kann ja schon mal
das GitHub Projekt machen. Shithub. Ist das ein Fiveheader Projekt oder ist es ein Wubblos
Projekt? Ich glaube, das ist ein Wubblos Projekt. WallpaperChamp. Wie nennen wir es denn? White
People Happy Desktop. Irgendwie sowas, oder? White People Happy Desktop Backgrounds. Wie
schreibt man das jetzt am besten? For every time of day, oder irgendwie sowas? Everyone. Irgendwie
sowas. Desktop Read Me License. Ja, Rackmann, welche License gibt denn das Ganze? Creative
Commons. Oh fuck. Zero Universal. Ich hab keine Ahnung. Wir lassen erst mal keine
Lizenz. Da können sich die Leute eigentlich offiziell gar nicht benutzen. Ja, ich kann
das nicht bestimmen. Ich hab die Bilder ja nicht gemacht. Okay. Yes. Repos. Das ist
Lizenz technisch eh nicht safe, aber da hast du wohl recht. Naja. Jetzt endlich wird's
kein Mensch interessieren. Okay. Wo haben wir die Sachen hier? Wurden die grad schon runtergeladen?
Nee, oder? Sag. Safe. Auf geht's. Von different daytimes. Ja, genau. Sowas in der Richtung. Wir
machen dann einfach die Bilder. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man gescheit die Bilder in... Hat
jemand mal eine GitHub-Readme gemacht mit irgendeiner Galerie oder sowas? Nee, ich glaub nicht.
Ich glaub, weiß gar nicht, ob es das geht. Ich mein, das ist ein Marktau und das kann alles
mögliche HTML. Wird schon funktionieren. Leute, morgen ist Feiertag, hab ich festgestellt. Guckt
mal. War mir neu. Ich mein, für mich ist es egal, weil... Naja, ich muss montags eh nicht arbeiten.
Irgendwie hab ich das jetzt erst gecheckt, dass morgen Feiertag ist.
Hast du dann drei Tage next week oder dadurch den Nachteil? Nee, ich hab nen Nachteil dadurch.
Nachteil, wenn du es so willst, ja. Der freie Tag ist verschenkt, also jeder hat Montag frei,
ich auch. Jaja, ich hab ganz normal vier Tage Woche. Ja, das trifft an 1-2 Tagen im Jahr zu,
damit kann ich leben. Jaja, ich hab nen Nachteil. Wie fällt dann Weihnachten dieses Jahr?
Wann ist Weihnachten 2023? Ok, Freitag. Montag? Wollt ihr mich verarschen?
Alter, das fällt ja mal richtig beschissen, ey.
Haha, das fällt ja mal mega scheiße, Alter.
Oh, das fällt ja mal richtig kacke.
Okay, das ist mies, das ist ja mal richtig mies, Alter.
Das fällt auch noch auf Montag, Mann.
Oh, das ist ja mal mega beschissen, Alter.
Ja, gut, gibt's Schlimmeres.
Das ist jetzt nicht so, das ist wirklich super, ganz furchtbar schrecklich, wieso ist das
kacke?
Weil ich Montags immer frei hab und ich ja deswegen nicht mehr und mehr bekomme.
Übrigens, guck mal, was ich gefunden habe auf Shithub vorhin.
Beste, ein Plants vs. Zombies Widescreen Mod.
Ich würde sagen, es ist mal wieder Zeit für neues Playthrough, allerdings diesmal mit
Widescreensupport.
Ich weiß übrigens nicht, wie lange es das schon gibt, anscheinend auch nicht so lange.
Widescreen Modge.
Das ist ein Game, das muss ich eigentlich so einmal alle 1-2 Jahre mal wieder durchspielen.
Das geht ja auch schnell, das hast du in 4-5 Stunden durch, das Gesamt.
Das ist ja tatsächlich so wahnsinnig, also gut, vielleicht 10 Stunden, wenn du alles
so die Sachen noch anlocken willst, aber...
Written in Rust? Nee, glaube ich nicht, das ist Written in...
Moment, warum ist das Written in Rust?
Okay, das schreibt irgendwelche Bites an irgendwelche Hex Offsets.
Na ja gut, ich weiß nicht, ob das unbedingt Written in Rust sein müsste.
Macht eigentlich relativ wenig Sinn, Written in Rust zu sein, oder?
Das patcht ja nur, das bringt ja keine Custom-Logik rein.
Also insofern war keine Ahnung, was das für einen Sinn macht.
Nun gut, wie dem auch sei...
Ich hab's zumindest heute entdeckt und ich dachte mir, es ist mal wieder Zeit für ein Replay.
Geht das mit der Origin-Version?
Oh, sorry, sorry, der EA-App-Version?
Wahrscheinlich.
Wobei, ich hab's, glaube ich, auch mittlerweile auf Steam.
Ich glaube, ich hab's auf allen Plattformen, die es gibt.
Ich hab's sogar auf der Xbox.
Wisst ihr, ich würde mich bei dem Spiel wirklich über den zweiten Teil freuen.
Den zweiten Teil, der halt auch den Namen verdient hat.
Der zweite Teil war halt ganz okay, aber auch schon komplett verschissen mit Microtransactions und allem.
Das ist echt so ein Paradebeispiel.
Wieder mache aus einem ganz guten, kleinen, netten Game irgendeinen Microtransaction Monster.
So einen richtig guten zweiten Teil, der einfach das macht, was der erste Teil gut gemacht hat.
Plus halt einfach noch mehr Levels und alles drum herum.
Ich glaube, es würde jeder feiern.
Aber der zweite Teil war halt Microtransaction versackt.
Zwei Reihen Sonnenblumen und Abfahrt, ja.
Wobei das beste Setup in Plants vs. Zombies ja immer noch das mit den Pilzen ist.
Das da.
Also für Leute, die noobs sind und die bisschen interaktiv was machen wollen, ist das Setup ganz nice.
Oder aber, man kann auch Endlos bauen, man kann auch Endless bauen.
Das sieht man dann im, ne Moment, das ist noch nicht das Endless Bild.
Das ist das komplette Endless Bild.
Und das ist wirklich nahezu, nahezu, ne das ist immer noch nicht das Endless Bild.
Die, die Garlix kommen noch weg, oder?
Ja, anscheinend doch nicht.
Es gibt, es gibt so ein Endless, so ein Endless.
Das hier meine ich.
Das kann man, das muss man aber alles anlockt haben.
Wobei die weißen Pilze sind glaube ich diese, die man anlocken kann.
Wobei die weißen Pilze sind glaube ich diese Kopie, diese Kopie Pilze.
Das ist so das Endless Setup.
Da ist da alles dabei, was du brauchst.
Das kannst du mehr oder weniger Endless laufen lassen.
Manchmal backt es rum, wenn dieser Michael Jackson Zombie mit, ne Moment.
Ne, wenn dieser Zombie mit der Box kommt.
Und der umkippt und es dann hier explodiert vorne.
Dann ist es nicht wirklich Endless, aber das geht nahezu Endless.
Das ist aber dann schon ein bisschen advanceder, wenn man das hier so sieht, ja.
Aber das müssen wir echt mal wieder spielen.
Hätte ich jetzt richtig Bock drauf.
So, was macht mein Download?
Download.
Drive, Download.
So, und das soll nach...
Repos, white, pepo, happy.
Clear.
Was?
Clear minus LA, ja.
Clear minus LS, alles klar.
MK, dir.
Images.
Drive, Download nach Images.
Unzip.
So, und jetzt haben wir unsere ganzen white, pepo, happy's hier.
Und hier können wir jetzt den Script reinhauen.
touchsetbg.sh oder sowas.
Was die Images switcht.
Ja, also, um euch das nochmal zu zeigen.
Der Rackman hat Hintergründe gebaut.
Für jede Tageszeit einen passenden Desktop-Hintergrund.
Äh, wie kann man sich das anzeigen lassen?
Also, guckt, seht ihr.
Man hat für jede Zeit einen passenden Desktop-Hintergrund.
Es gibt Sonnenuntergangs, white, pepo, happy's.
Die gucken natürlich Oldschool-Ultra-Skiller.
Dann gibt's das Ganze nochmal, wo alt man durch die Sonne untergeht.
Dann gibt's den Sonnenaufgang.
Nee, das ist nochmal Sunset. Der guckt immer noch.
Ach, das ist mit Planket und das andere, der ist cozy.
Okay.
Dann gibt's Sunrise. Da putzt er Zähne.
Das ist nicht für jede Stunde.
So für jede Tageszeit hast du drinnen.
So, das ist Sonnenaufgang.
Dann hast du jede Menge Bilder, wo er schläft.
Ähm, was heißt jede Menge? Du hast gar nicht so viele.
Du hast die alle nur mit Mond und ohne Mond.
Da träumt er verschiedene Sachen.
Dann gibt's den noch.
Und dann gibt's den noch.
Da träumt er verschiedene Sachen.
Dann gibt's den noch.
Sonnenaufgang mit Futter.
Und dann gibt's den noch.
Tagsüber Mittagessen, Cookies, Futtern und Arbeiten.
So, das heißt, wir bauen uns jetzt ein Skript,
was quasi guckt, so von der Uhrzeit her,
welche Uhrzeit es ist und dann den Hintergrund setzt.
Die Hintergründe werde ich auch so hochladen,
also im Endeffekt, die kann sich auch jeder selbst crappen
und das Skript muss man dafür auch gar nicht.
Das kann ich benutzen, ja.
Wie erfolgt der Abnahmetest des Skripts?
24 Stunden.
Das dürft ihr dann ausprobieren.
Ja, also wir machen irgendwie sowas von,
ich weiß nicht, von 6 Uhr ist Sunrise,
von 8 Uhr ist Morning,
von 11 Uhr ist Tag,
ab 18 Uhr ist Sunset,
und ab 20 Uhr ist dann irgendwie Night.
Irgendwie sowas.
Und ab 21 Uhr ist Night.
Dann, dass man alle Bilder auch eine Chance hat zu sehen.
Erstmal Scrum.
Na Moment, erstmal müssen wir unser Kanban Board,
unseren Scrum Master ernennen dafür.
Leute, wer hat Scrum Master?
Wer hat Agile Erfahrung von euch?
Jetzt müssen wir, jetzt machen wir es richtig.
Leute, Daily.
Ligat hat Scrum...
Okay, Ligat ist unser Scrum Master.
Der muss uns sagen, wenn wir das Agile Mindset nicht richtig einhalten.
Lass safe machen.
Ja, also wie gesagt, ein Kanban Board sollten wir auf jeden Fall anlegen.
Ja, erstmal denke ich auch, erstmal ein Kanban Board erstellen.
Warum nicht das Ganze nach Sonnenstand, Mondstand?
Weil du dann irgendwie abfragen müsstest, wie der Sonnenstand, Mondstand ist.
Irgendwie auch passend zum...
Äh, zur Zeitzone.
Und wo du auf der Erde bist. Also gut, halt, Zeitzone.
Das ist mir für den Bash Script ein bisschen zu kompliziert.
Aber du kannst ja selbst was bauen, wenn dir das zu billig ist.
Dann müsste ich ihn mal fragen. Weiß ich grad nicht.
Da gibt's doch sicherlich ein Paket. Ich weiß nicht.
Ich hab keins gefunden, was tagesformabhängig Background setzen kann.
Und was dann auch anhand des Namens das rausfällt.
Wenn ich... Ich meine, das kann jeder benutzen, wie er will.
Ich lad die Bilder ja hoch.
Eine coole Idee.
Aber das kackt halt ab, wenn mal das Internet nicht geht.
Ich mach jetzt erst mal Hardcoded.
Ihr könnt euch dann, wenn ihr wollt, am Bashscript oder am Skript auslassen
und alles Mögliche einbauen.
Ich werd' einfach Pull-Requests, äh, plintmergen.
Weil der Chat macht ja prinzipiell keine Fehler beim Programmieren.
Dann muss man das auch nicht machen.
Und dann kann ich auch mal was machen.
Der Chat macht ja prinzipiell keine Fehler beim Programmieren.
Dann muss man das auch nicht überprüfen.
Machen wir jetzt Kanban oder Scrum?
Wir machen beides, weil wir sind ja ein agiles T-Shaped-Team.
Die Musik ist ein bisschen laut, hä?
Jetzt ist die Frage, wo hab ich die Music auf da?
Scrumbun, genau.
Das ist eher Scrum-Ban.
Ok, Bash-Magic, Leute.
Bash-Magic-Time.
Ok, erst mal alles hinzufügen.
Oh, die Bilder sind ganz schön groß.
What the fuck?
Hol...
Jesus.
Alter, wie fett sind bitteschön die Bilder.
What the...
Oh, das sind ordentlich pepo-fette Bilder.
Welche Auflösung haben die Bilder eigentlich?
Ich dachte, die sind bloß 1080p, oder nicht?
Ach nee, das sind 4K-Bilder.
Eher noch viel geiler.
Okay, nice.
Da sind die ja sogar 4K-certified.
Git-LFS.
Quatsch, das wird einfach committed und gut ist.
Mir doch egal, das ist nicht mein Speicherplatz.
Okay.
Bin.
Bash.
Ich weiß, manche schreien jetzt rum.
Oh, was muss bin denn?
Ist mir egal.
Jeder hat eine Bash installiert.
Ja.
Wie machen wir das?
Wie machen wir das jetzt gescheit, Leute?
Ich muss da mal kurz überlegen.
Wie kriege ich denn jetzt eine Liste mit allen meinen Files hier zusammen?
Find.
So was.
Und dann irgendwie type F.
Ja, dann hat man es doch.
Und dann grab nach xpepo.
So, dann hat man die Bilder.
Nice.
Okay.
Und dann sortieren, dass es immer die gleichen Reihenfolge gibt.
Okay, das finde ich schon mal.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Das brauchen wir jetzt.
Files.
Gleich.
So.
Da haben wir jetzt unsere Bilder drinnen.
Wir könnten mit den Bildern auch NFTs und einen Champ kommen.
Ja, na klar.
Na klar.
Wie heißt diese Kryptobörse?
Da, wo die alle ihre Shit-NFTs verkaufen.
Aber ich hab's vergessen.
Wenn ich den Namen lese, weiß ich sofort wieder.
Und ich meine nicht, ich meine nicht.
Ja, genau, dieses Ding.
Ja, genau, das meine ich.
Ich werde nie NFTs machen, Leute.
Der Hype ist ja auch schon ziemlich wieder vorbei.
Nee, ich meinte Dings hier.
Ich meinte Open Seas oder Open CS oder wie soll man das ausspricht?
So, hier haben wir unsere Files.
Jetzt brauchen wir noch...
Was ist denn das nochmal?
Date?
Date minus...
Nee.
Was war das?
Date prozent H?
Date...
Oder nee, plus.
Plus ist es, glaube ich.
Plus H, okay.
Also das ist die Stunde.
Date plus prozent H.
Das müssen wir nicht checken.
Das hat jeder auf dem Rechner drauf.
KI ist jetzt der Hotshit.
Wen jucken NFTs?
Wen juckt Web 3.0 noch?
Hat jemand von euch Web 3.0?
In den letzten paar Wochen, Monaten mal gehört.
Nee.
Da war nur AI.
Und nochmal AI und AI.
In irgendeiner Art und Weise.
Und vielleicht ein bisschen, ein bisschen
Ausläufer von Blockchain-Kryptogramm
noch.
Das ist ja immer so ein bisschen
Grundrauschen.
War das Web?
Nee, ich glaube es war Web 3.0, oder?
Oder Web 3 war das?
War das?
Ich glaube es war Web 3.0.
Dieses ganze.
Allerdings muss ich ehrlich sagen,
ich sehe es wie Erbsenraube.
Also von den beiden Trends
ist mit dem Machine Learning Trend auf jeden
Fall lieber als
der ganze Krypto-Shit.
Was machen eigentlich diese ganzen
Krypto-Scam-Games, die immer so
mit super viel Hype verbunden waren?
Da ist doch noch kein einziges
rausgekommen. Da gab es doch
dieses super Scammy-Game.
Wie ist das? Earth?
Irgendwas mit Earth?
To Earth?
Oder irgendwie sowas?
Second Earth? Nee, das war Second Life.
Double Earth? Earth 2.0?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Dieses Ding, wo du virtuell
auf einer Karte Länder kaufen
konnt. Ernsthaft? Wirklich?
Alter, das ist der größte
Shit überhaupt. Warum
hat man da Geld reingesteckt?
Cryptoland!
Ja, den Shit gab es auch noch. Alter!
Ich glaube, mit den
meisten Sachen haben noch nicht mal die Erfinder
Geld verdient.
Stimmt!
Und was macht eigentlich das
Metaverse?
Was macht eigentlich so das
Ja, Spigge. Wild Paper Happy.
Was macht eigentlich das Metaverse so?
Ja, der Zug, der dreht halt
immer noch am Rad.
Die Hälfte der Erwachsenen weiß nicht,
was das Metaverse ist. Ich bezweifle,
dass die Leute,
die andere Hälfte ist wirklich weiß.
Das weiß glaube ich Facebook selber noch nicht mal so richtig.
Die National Hockey League hat eine
Dynamic Metaverse Experience
in Roblox.
Ist das jetzt eine Verarschung
oder hat das wirklich
jemand so geschrieben?
Eine Dynamische Metaverse
in Roblox. Roblox?
Das ist ja eine Verarschung!
Oh, hier war das eben Roblox. Roblox?!
Meine Güte!
Na gut, da hat irgend so ein komischer
BWL-Stonks-Typ von denen gehört
jetzt drei Jahre nachdem es angesagt war.
Ha, Metavaus...
Oh, da müssen wir auch etwas machen!
Zwei...
Das meine ich, den Müll gibt's ja immer noch.
Außer dieses komische Video
gibt's ja da nix. Das ist ja kein
Game oder sowas. Die haben ja
angefangen mit, es soll ein Game werden,
würde halt nie ein Game und wird auch nie ein Game.
Ist auch so eine Unreal
5 Demo wieder gewesen.
Wo sie mit irgend so einem Auto
durch irgendwie pre-rendert...
äh, nicht pre-rendert...
Keine Ahnung, auto-generated
Weltgefahren sind
total unsinnig, alter.
Ja, goodluck.
Du chebatest uns doch eh.
Du hast wahrscheinlich gar nichts investiert da drin.
Scamverse, ja und von dieser
Richtung gab es ja noch total viel andere Sachen.
Ok, jetzt lass uns mal ganz schnell mal
unseren Bash-Script, da gucken wir vielleicht noch ein paar Videos.
Das sollte ja nicht allzu lang dauern.
Unserem Fiveheader
Bash-Script mit einem...
Ähm...
Wie kriegt man raus in einem
Bash-Script?
In welchem Verzeichnis das Script ist?
Äh...
Bash-Get-Script-Directory.
How do I get the directory where a Bash-Script is located?
Excellent.
Genau das brauch ich.
What?
Was ist das für
Magic?
Okay, meint ihr das funktioniert?
CD-minusminus.
Was?
Was macht CD-minusminus?
Ach ne, Moment.
Minusminus ist nur, dass danach keine
Optionen mehr kommen.
Ich glaub, deswegen ist Minusminus.
Was anderes ergibt keinen Sinn.
So, und dann?
DNA-minusminus.
Immer Minusminus.
Warum immer Minusminus?
Macht er an der Stelle?
Dear name?
Bash
Source null?
MonkaW
Was macht das denn?
Und vor allem, warum hat der Typ
Doublequotes in Doublequotes? Das ist doch auch schon mal
Nicht so geil ist.
Echo Dear
Guck mal ob das funktioniert.
Moment
Wenn ich das jetzt so richtig schreiben würde, dann würde es auch vielleicht
Funktionieren.
CMOD plus X
ZBG
Tatsächlich funktioniert es. Stackoverflow weiß einfach
Bescheid. Ich habe zwar keine Ahnung
Was es genau macht,
Aber nice.
Ultrabash Magic ist das.
Okay, weil
Weil
True
Do
Sleep
Alle 5 Sekunden checken wir ob eine neue Tageszeit ist.
Okay, also
Dann lass uns das doch mal ausprobieren.
Was ist das?
Egal, haben wir doch schon.
Also
Das heißt wir gucken jetzt.
If
If die Stunde
Ist größer als
Machen wir es einfach von oben nach unten.
Die Stunde ist größer als
Dann
Okay
So wenn die Stufe größer als 20 ist
Äh nicht die Stufe
Wenn die Stunde größer als 20 ist
Dann ist es
Nacht
Moment
Bash Comments sind so
Äh Moment
Also ab 21 Uhr ist Nacht
Das ist doch ganz okay
Ab 21 Uhr ist Nacht
Das ist doch in Ordnung
Kann man doch sagen
Das nächste ist sagen wir
Ab 18 Uhr
Ist
Sunset
Sagt wenn es keinen Sinn macht
Was ich eingebe
So
Dann sagen wir ab
Ab wann ist Mittag bzw. ab wann ist Tag
Ab
Ab 11
Day
Ab 8
Ab 8 ist Sunrise
Und als letztes brauchen wir noch
Els
Und das ist Nacht
Ergibt das Sinn?
Ich hoffe das ergibt Sinn
Okay
So dann gucken wir mal kurz wie wir den Background setzen
Wie mache ich das denn hier?
BG Phil
Okay
Images
Coffee
Ja funktioniert
Okay
Auer ist da hinter
Du könntest auch, ja das könnte ich wahrscheinlich machen
Da hast du recht
Wisst ihr was? Wir fragen danach mal
Wenn wir fertig sind, fragen wir mal
JetGPT ob sie das
Bash Script optimieren und
Verbessern kann
Mal gucken ob da was
Sinnvolles bei rauskommt
So ich würde sagen
Jetzt müssen wir an der Stelle
Lass mal testen, welcher Fall trifft denn jetzt zu
Größer 17 Uhr trifft zu
Also jetzt müssen wir
Das Background
Setzen und das Background
Wie machen wir das jetzt am besten?
Also das hier ist
Das hier ist Sunset
Okay
Wir müssen jetzt
Von dem Ordner in dem das Skript
Klickt
Random
Ein Image rauspicken
Also das ist schon mal
Blödsinn das muss schon mal so rum
Und an die Stelle muss
Dir
So
Okay
Random Image rauspicken das hatten wir letzten
Mal schon mal Echo
Files
Nach
Ne jetzt müssen wir erstmal die Bilder
rausfiltern
Die wir haben wollen was mit Sunset
Also die Dinger heißen dann sowas wie
Max
Underscore
Sunset
Holen wir mal aus hier
Images
Ne Moment
Sunset
Ja
Also die Dinger heißen sowas wie
Sunset
So
Fangfan
B2